[Music]
hey everybody welcome to episode 14
yeah we're - why do I never remember
that I don't know it's a good show
though oh it's a good show Tom who's off
now as you know we just recorded it we
don't usually have a lot of guests on
our podcast you know the last one we
have was the angry gay Pope we generally
only ask people to be on the show if we
really really like them but yes it's a
real good guest yeah and so we were very
very excited to have our next guest on I
don't know if you guys know who he is
but his name is dr. Robert M price and
he's known as the Bible geek yes he has
a channel called the Bible geek uh he is
an atheist and a Jesus mythos
yeah um but he is also fascinated by the
Bible and by the mythology of it and the
Bible and he is a just has encyclopedic
knowledge yeah this guy his brain is
like a rotary engine it once it spools
up
it just goes a million miles an hour all
right and it's just it's awesome that's
awesome you land really and I get I get
tongue-tied around because I'm totally
starstruck and yeah yes I was a huge fan
I've been a huge fan of reasons we
listen to his to his like Genesis
studies and stuff like that we listen to
him where we're going to sleep sometimes
so uh you know we've we've Island um
dear today where you're working yeah
yeah so we've listened to open a bunch
of times but he's really he's a super
fascinating guy and you learn a lot
about him and yeah and he's really funny
and really entertaining now I mean we
wanted to do I mean we kind of want to
do like a broad overview of some
biblical mythology and some Jesus mythos
isms a huge huge topic and we only had
one so but I think we kind of covered a
lot of ground in the interview and this
is just tip of the iceberg if you ended
this kind of stuff you just go on his
channel you can ask questions you know
it there's just tons and tons of this
stuff and yeah awesome just super
fascinating and so what we're going to
do I mean we we recorded the the
interview separately just now so what
we're going to do is because we didn't
want to interrupt him for commercials
and stuff is I'm going to put in a
commercial break right now with all the
commercials and then after that
you know he will just talk for an hour
unimpeded and then we'll come back and
give a little close-up with our stuff
and stuff like that so I hope you guys
enjoy this as much as we enjoy doing it
I didn't hardly talk during it all in
because I just wanted yeah wanted him to
go and we will have him back on uh he
he's also good with H P Lovecraft's yeah
he's also he also writes fiction and a
Lovecraftian vanities and is also um
Lovecraft scholar he also has a channel
there's a channel or a blog called the
Lovecraft geek yeah so we are definitely
going to have him on at another point
talking about HP logos the mythology
behind comic book characters everything
yeah yeah so um so without further delay
I will play our commercial break and
then we will have an hour of interview
with Robert M price project
Entertainment Network presents butter
cup of doom with your host Kelly Owen
just a girl a girl who writes horror and
thriller fiction talks to bugs jumps and
puddles and now hosts a weekly podcast
full of opinions advice and a touch of
gypsy wisdom whether it's current
affairs or social media nightmares join
me as I rant and rave and offer up a big
old bucket a common sense Wednesday's on
Buttercup of doom if you are into
cosplay course 'try steampunk gothic or
rockabilly clothing shoes and
accessories then you must visit
subculture corsets and clothing either
online at www.haddadtoyota.com code 13
o'clock and receive a 10% discount on
your entire order and if you're a
full-figured girl don't worry
subculture carries sizes 4 through 4x
and they have men's clothing as well
that's subculture corsets calm and use
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount go check out their website now
subculture corsets calm or when
traveling through Jacksonville Florida
stop in and check out their store at the
Avenues Mall
is uh it's bazan Buzard we're the kid
pot head busted by me mr. Frank fazham
is the showcase podcast of the bizarro
fiction genre and those are right weird
and read weird are gonna love this pot
as we're eating become to everyone
anyone and the bizarre and weird fiction
grills so join us here every Monday
presented exclusively by the project
enter teaming there's hair is real and
imaginary and I write about them all
paranormal nonfiction or fiction rushed
a lobster guys the Mammoth Mountain
culture associated monster Red Menace
the tenth of Rosella weather go to WWJD
Ashbrook calm or search Amazon for the
Jenny Ashford author page
[Music]
dr. price it sir it's a real honor to
have you on the show a great pleasure to
be on it yeah it's uh I'm almost
speechless talking to you because I've
been one of your students for years and
I'm really happy to be a patron dr.
price could you introduce yourself to
the audience well I am now what they
euphemized not to say euthanize as an
independent scholar I my classroom
teaching days are behind me and I'm
happily free of having great papers and
the like and I'd now spend my time
reading researching writing and having a
great time at it my educational
background I always hate to say training
because that sort of implies you just
like a dog trying to jump through hoops
or something but my educational
background was I was at Montclair State
College and graduated from there with a
double major in history and religion and
the minors in classics then I want to
went on to gordon-conwell seminary and
interdenominational evangelical seminary
and studied New Testament there was just
like a two-year master's in New
Testament and after that immediately I
took a few more courses at Montclair
some of the good ones
on were anthropology sociology religion
stuff like that but I hadn't been able
to squeeze in the first time around then
I went to oh yeah well I was at
gordon-conwell I also took some courses
at Boston University School of Theology
Harvard Divinity School of Princeton
seminary all of which were just enormous
ly fascinating and so then I went to
Drew University in Madison New Jersey
and took a PhD degree in systematic
theology and this was in I guess I guess
I finished it up in 81 and then I
for some years and then eventually went
back to Drew and we've got a second PhD
in New Testament and again all of it was
just so great I pester friends of mine
Bible eggs and others that they ought to
go back and get a doctoral degree a New
Testament even if they can't get a job
which they probably can so you're known
as the Bible geek how can how can people
find you online
I guess just do a search for the Bible
geek I can't keep addresses and stuff
like that in my head yes I'm sure Bible
eats a youth problem yeah and yet you
haven't you have a YouTube channel and I
think that's it right just YouTube and a
patreon that's right you know at my own
website is Robert M price got to mind
vendor dot-com and that's got a big
archive of short stories sermons columns
articles and all kinds of stuff and you
can subscribe for free there to my
monthly column a newsletter Zarathustra
speaks and I guess there's a link to the
patreon page ooh and you've written a
lot of books too yeah a bunch in I've
edited a whole lot of fiction
anthologies in the vein of HP Lovecraft
and I've had one collection of my
stories in the Lovecraft field published
a book called blasphemies and
revelations but then in the area of
religion I've had a lot of stuff
published books on the historical Jesus
like deconstructing Jesus being the
Incredible Shrinking Son of Man the
Christ myth theory and its problems and
so on and I did a real long one on Paul
called the amazing colossal apostle I
did my own New Testament translation
called the pre Nicene New Testament and
there's all kinds of other ones
on the shelf wearing worse now what
makes you so special is that you're a
myth assist and an atheist and you love
the Bible you're not anti Bible or anti
religion at all can you explain this to
us house yeah it's at once that an
article called is the Bible Mind Kampf
because a lot of atheists of many of
whom are reacting against conservative
religious past seem to think it's just
filled with with evil and reprehensible
barbarism and all that and it's it's
like they're still looking at it through
the same old prism in a sense and they
just don't like it anymore but it's for
me like the thing that got me out of
believing in biblical Authority and
literalism and all that was that if you
figured okay now this is the Word of God
it can't have any mistakes it can't have
the writers contradicting each other
if you approached it with those blinders
on it just often made no sense and
because it sure looks like this one
contradicts this one if this guy do
interpreting says no you're
hallucinating price it really doesn't
that that can't be right
it's like a Christian sign as well I
seem to be sick but I guess I'm not
human Aaron C is the Christian Science
approach to the Bible well so eventually
a lot of us come to this point
you figure you know I gotta decide
between believing in the authority of
the Bible and understanding the Bible
and it's got its hook at me I'm so
curious about it that even if I don't
believe anymore
I really am fascinated by this work and
so you move into a kind of like a
mentality of a classicist who doesn't
first switch second thing that Zeus and
Athena and Achilles ever existed is it
interesting
I suppose you then found out that there
was some sect out there that said oh no
no the Iliad and the Odyssey are
literally true you gotta believe in Zeus
and so forth and equal time for Zeus in
classroom but think wait a minute I
share what I know about the Iliad and
the Odyssey not because I hate it and
want to combat it because because I love
it and don't want to see it abused right
and so that's kind of the way I view the
Bible it's just so fascinating and all
the more if you don't feel obliged to
believe what kind of book is the Bible
in its entirety I know it's a huge
subject but what are they trying to tell
us with this book well it's the kind of
a cultural library of ancient Judaism
and early Christianity and there are all
kinds of writings in it the Old
Testament has a number of sets of song
lyrics the Psalms which were the hymn
book of the Jerusalem Temple and the
Song of Solomon which probably was the
liturgy of the worship of Tammuz and
Ishtar before they change the names
their proverbs in it like collections of
wise sayings that are still really great
stuff nobody should have any trouble
with those there's there are boring
parts of it for the general reader
because they weren't written for general
consumption of and nothing was back then
because there was no real way to make
anything popular you can go oh sorry I
gave me a copy of bît-yakin
and even if you did it you wouldn't
understand it because it wasn't written
for you so it's like a technical manual
for Levitical priests why the heck are
there all these genealogies well it was
credentials for priests and kings it
wasn't supposed to be interesting even
much less entertaining but then the
stories which we all like best a lot of
those were anecdotes written to
legitimate social arrangements like
support nation of women to men certainly
that's one of the big things of the Eden
story some of them were written just to
are told to explain puzzling things when
no scientific explanation was available
like why your snakes crawl and do they
hate it or like it though them as they
belittle God must have punished them
yeah and why do we wear clothes I mean
other animals don't but the head and so
here's the Eden story again why is this
odd rock formation here it kind of looks
like a figure of a woman standing out
here in the middle of Globex that's the
prototype for the morton salt label
Lot's wife and and there are other
similar myths and legends in other
countries they show the same sort of
thing
what is the rainbow obviously these
people do nothing about light refraction
how could they so one thing I always
like to point out the students we are
tempted to think the ancients were
stupid and of course they were not they
just didn't have access to technology
yet and so these myths are themselves
the product of a creative intelligence
so they said well it looks kind of like
a war bow and Jehovah's a storm God he
must must have shot his lightning bolts
from this bow and he tried to flood us
all out but then thought better of it
said okay I'm hanging up the bow like
I'm hanging up the gloves it's pretty
good it's factually incorrect why did
the Genesis one writer think that the
earth was covered by a solid dome and
floating on a universal ocean was that
stupid no it's not even mythology it's
like the pre-socratic natural
philosophers and that's what they said
is what it actually looks like until he
had telescopes and so on so there's all
kinds of inventive in or what why were
certain things given place names that
didn't make any sense anymore even way
back then and so they kind of try to
break down the long word like they are
will hire Roy
does that mean well of something and so
they broke it down the well of one who
sees and lives and so we get the story
of Hagar who saves her life by drinking
water out of this well because an angel
shows it to her and she says have I seen
the angel of the Lord and live to tell
it ha the well of one who sees and lives
where as it actually meant the well of
the antelopes jawbone is just describing
the lay of the land so you could find
the thing and it's just filled with
stuff like that and it's not whether
there's some imposture and priests craft
as they used to call it sometimes you
try to get away with something but a lot
of it's just a collection of great old
sagas and legends and so on then the New
Testament is more the same with the
Gospels in fact I kind of think that
virtually all the stories of the Gospels
are rewrites some closer some freer of
Old Testament stories and then they're
treatises like the Pauline epistles
explaining different versions of
Christian doctrine and they all kind of
share a similar religious and cultural
milieu but there certainly is no
unanimity of belief or doctrine and
there certainly it's certainly not
really a source for history so you can
be disappointed that but I just need you
were looking for the wrong thing and
it's just it's a grab bag and a
fascinating well let's let's go back to
Genesis what kind of what kind of world
are they talking about what kind of God
is this they're talking about I noticed
that there were their terms for
addressing God are very different you'll
hear L you'll hear Yahweh you'll also
hear the word Halloween is this is this
one God they're talking about or have
they harmonized several gods it appears
that the latter is the case and on the
one hand there's there's a good amount
of evidence that they shared these gods
with the surrounding tribes and
nations we already knew that for a long
time with LEL and which is the root of
though the Muslim name Allah it means
God and and that apparently the root for
that is the strong one but a lot of
people it was a name that it was generic
you look at the Canaanite documents that
came to light over a century ago and
they've got some of the same names for
the same God so they're worshiping the
same deity just slightly different
stories Yahweh or Jehovah we had thought
for a long time was a distinctive name
for uh the the God of Israel but it
turns out even that is not true because
Bale was sometimes called Yahweh and
apparently there were various other
peoples in the Middle East that
worshiped God in Yahweh or Jehovah and
it looks at look and there were there
was apparently a for a long time a whole
pantheon of Israelite deities and the
notion was that L also called el elyon
God Most High he was the king of the
gods and he had 70 sons the famous sons
of God that pop up in the Old Testament
and he divided in Deuteronomy 32 says
that he divided up mankind into enough
nation so that each of the sons of God
would would be able to be worshipped by
his own nation and that's referred to
various other times in the Old Testament
and that Yahweh was his one of the sons
of El Elyon and he was in charge of
Israel so later on this they began to
streamline the whole thing so that the
some of the I guess the ruling
theologians decided that El Elyon and
Yahweh were the same God just different
names and and these other gods were were
angels and so they they tinkered with
that as they
centuries went on we only find a
monotheism in the books of Isaiah and
Jeremiah which even if the traditional
dates are right are pretty late but for
you can tell reading the various stories
that Israelites for a long time weren't
yet monotheists but were manometers
which means worshipers of one God not
denying that there are other gods like
in Exodus 20 when the preamble of the
Ten Commandments I am Yahweh your God
who delivered you out of the house of
bondage you shall have no other gods
alongside me well that that's not a
statement of monotheism it's saying I am
the one to whom you owe this great debt
and so you will worship me and not
others and that implies there are others
it's just that they're not your God
you've got no business with them yeah
though that wasn't that that's
prescriptive not descriptive record and
and a lot of the Old Testament stuff the
the writers are trying to get people to
embrace monotheism a new idea so you can
trace the evolution of even God in the
Bible so you have God his sons and then
it says that his sons mate with mortal
women and then making Nephilim well
that's the same as the Greek pantheon
you have Zeus his sons and then having
sex with mortal women producing demigods
it's it's like the Greek system it's
like a Greek pantheon yeah and there may
even be some overlap there's a reason to
think that Samson is just the Hebrew
version of Hercules okay if he's not he
certainly fits the same slot both were
originally son gods who were then cut
down to size as myth became legend and
gods became demigods they were on the
earth among human beings but they were
half God that this is a process that
happens in a lot of religions so and it
says that the Nephilim were the mighty
men of
well that that's the epic heroes like
Gilgamesh who's mentioned in the Dead
Sea Scrolls they they believed in him
and and Samson and Nimrod who it was the
same as the Greek Orion the Titan and so
yeah it was exactly the same sort of
stuff and my guess is like in the Samson
story and several others where the the
mother-to-be is not get pregnant because
either
well they say she's barren but more than
likely the husband was sterile and so
that she is impregnated by the angel of
Yahweh or whatever I'm making an
educated guess that in those stories God
in human form did actually impregnate
the women exactly is in Greek mythology
but that got kind of cleaned up too so
it is I think just the same now in
Exodus Moses speaks to the burning bush
who does this burning bush claim to be
is well there are ways of getting around
that if you didn't want God to be down
and dirty on earth with with humans if
he says that I am that I am but tell
them that I am has sent me ice as the
Moses tell them that Yahweh has sent me
to pun cuz if this they're figuring that
goth way comes from hai-yah to be in
Hebrew but at any rate he's certainly
being addressed by the voice of God well
later rabbis said yeah that's a little
hard to imagine the transcendent Lord of
the universe showing up in a fireworks
display on a mountainside in
Nowheresville and so they said well he
was speaking through that but it was an
angel of Yahweh Oh an angel just means
messenger and so there was a way of sort
of wriggling out of it and that sounds
kind of fishy but it shows that they
were going for a more transcendent
nearly philosophical view of God and had
to try to make sense of the old stories
which is just what the Greeks did to the
Stoics they invented allegory to take
crude and and morally embarrassing
stories and to say well it doesn't
really mean that it means something
Maura lore philosophical and apparently
Jews got it from from the Greeks okay so
the when Moses is on the top of the
mountains it sounds a lot like he's
talking to a volcano if you ask me
there's fire up there fire on the top of
the mountain is that a bail symbol or is
that more symbolic of bail or is it
Yahweh or did this was this story
originally about another God was it was
it a story that was adapted I mean from
from another damn it it's hard to say it
does presuppose the storm god image and
the fire is very likely supposed to be
lightning flashes sometimes it denotes
that and there's the heavy cloud and the
thundering and the trumpets and so forth
he is pictured often in the Bible as a
storm God again like zoom store Indre
etc and also a war God because they were
often the same thing because the the
crashing in the heavens was the flash of
divine armies and so on and so he's
pictured as storm God atop the mountain
and baled was a storm God both are
described in their different
literature's as riding cloud chariots
the the cherubim are apparently
personified clouds and so that they're
either just exact counterparts or two
names for the same deity and I lean
toward the latter in the Prophet Hosea
God says the day is coming when you will
no longer call me my veil but my husband
Bale means master but
was like a name and his full title was a
Leon bail which seems to be the same
thing as la Leon Bay over most high and
one Canaanite text says that bails name
is Jung a short version of Yahweh so I
six of one half a dozen of the other I
think they simply were the same God
worshiped a bit a bit differently by
cousin Jason groups I got I guess so
it's like two different cuts in the same
religion worship the same God in
different ways that might explain why
there is a part that there's a part in
the Bible where in the Old Testament
where you have a priest of the cult of
Yahweh and then a priest of the cult of
Bale both in a competition to call down
fire out of the sky that's right yeah
you eyes on the prophets of hail and it
even says that there are like 450
prophets of Bale and another 400 of a
shara it was widely worshipped in Israel
too there were images of her all over
the place that the Bible mentions and
condemns well that was the same in the
Canaanite Pantheon though the God and
Goddess and in fact we have reliefs from
I believe either in Israel or adjacent
to it where it shows two seated figures
and it says Yahweh and his a Sharad so
they had know that there was a male and
a female God God and the divine consorts
for a long long time so like Zeus and
Hera exactly right Wow interesting
okay what about Elijah and Elijah are
they the same person
I give very seldom hear that guess but
you have to wonder given that the names
are so similar however I think that
originally they they represented one of
the many astrological or astronomical
back then myths about the Sun and the
moon striving to replace one another
they would often take celestial
phenomena that happen all the time
and tell a story about them where it's a
one time event and so Elijah it seems to
be a Sun God says that he's a hairy man
in second Kings 1a you saw this guy oh
this prophet what did he look like oh he
was a hairy man okay oh my god it's
Elijah and that's for the the sun's rays
like Hercules killing the Nemean lion
with a mane and Samson having the seven
great locks of hair he's the Sun God his
name even means the Sun and like Samson
he does stuff with fire he calls down
fire from heaven to kill the Samaritan
soldiers and so on and when he leaves
the earth he boards a fiery chariot and
ascends to the zenith of the heavens
come on obviously he's a Sun God well
the one that's the only description we
ever hear of him that he's a hairy man
but it means his closer's there on his
head who knows but the only thing we
ever hear about Elijah is that he's bald
and the famous story God Baal deadly six
the Bears on him well why tell us that
he's bald well because he's the move and
and so the Sun leaves and the moon
replaces it it's the same thing with
Jacob who is a smooth man and Esau who
is a hairy man and and there are many
examples of this and uh so that's
probably the origin of the myth and that
would make me say neither probably
understood it's two different characters
so really nothing in the Old Testament
is actually historical it's all
mythological I would say so if there are
in the latter parts of it references to
actual Kings Omri and Jehu and all that
and it's possible that bets
of these least interesting parts of the
Old Testament are historical but these
things are purely naturalistic there's
there's nothing about God is showing up
at a door like I mean Jehovah's
Witnesses will in the abraham story
jehovah shows up at the door and you
don't have that it's like they're more
in touch with a real world the later you
go but i think that's the big mark of
old testament minimalism that there's
the barest minimum of historical
information very late that there may
well never have been a day that a
solomon much less of moses is there
does anyone is there any way to date the
Old Testament there are educated guesses
but none of them are certain and the
first real scientific critics Groff and
Bell House and - none of these guys in
the 19th century they saw that Genesis
through Deuteronomy had to be the
product of a bunch of different earlier
source documents harmonized like people
do with the Gospels today you find
several editions of people trying to
weave them together and get all the
stories in our laws of order well that's
what they did and so they they dated
each one of them and said well let's see
the the J source the document that
refers to God is Jehovah or Yahweh that
must be around the time of the Solomon
or Rita bone somewhere 900 BCE and the e
document where they call God Elohim that
kind of overlaps J and the stories where
they overlap seems to have a more
advanced doctored up polished up version
so there must be a little bit later and
they figured maybe around 800 and then
the the priestly well they figured maybe
the book of Deuteronomy must come from
around the reign of King Josiah so that
put that around seven-30 and the
sleek code must have been written during
the exile by the priest so that would
make it somewhere around 500 and that
was reasonable and they had good
evidence for it but of course it's
hypothetical
and now over century later everything
has changed it still seems like they
divided the text correctly that you can
spot these different sources and their
signature marks but there's now reason
to believe that that the Exodus story
may have been based on an Egyptian book
by of the priests Manito who had a
version of the the israelites being
expelled from Egypt and Genesis maybe
based on the work of a Babylonian priest
named Berossus wrote in Greek and it's
like there's so much overlap these
stories and no others that if this is
true then the Genesis and Exodus at
least would seem to be something like
third century BCE and much much later
than we thought and not that far removed
from the New Testament I think that
they're even later than that of the
Septuagint the Greek translation of the
Old Testament was done in in the
Ptolemaic Empire Hellenistic Egypt and
that we figured and they figured that
was in the third century BCE well it now
looks like possibly the Hebrew and the
Greek Old Testament were written by the
same people at the same time and that
puts it really late and if I'm not
mistaken it it's even later than that it
might be something like the second
century BC so it's not as old as we
thought by a longshot the relative dusts
pretty darn oh so they're all they're
basically reboots oh yeah I mean we
figured that anyway because of the flood
stories being so similar and you can see
how things in Genesis look so much like
stuff from the
kappa myth and the Gilgamesh epic a big
chunk of the proverbs seems to be based
on the wisdom of Amon and Moses in Egypt
and things like that it kind of looks
like a lot of it was sort of second hand
adaptation anyhow or even the the the
book of the Covenant the oldest part of
the law code in Genesis looks like it
was based on the Code of Hammurabi and
so actually Thomas Aquinas dealt with
this way back in the Middle Ages because
even if you took it all literally it's
obvious that some of the Bible is
explicitly based on earlier documents
says we got this from the books of the
kings of Judah and all that and he says
well there's that's the difference
between revelation and inspiration
yeah these originals weren't revealed by
God they're not revelation but they're
inspiration because the Holy Spirit
guided the redaction in editing
he was already coping with that sort of
thing and some Roman Catholic
theologians have a very similar
sophisticated approach to it today like
Raymond Brown and a lot of these guys
they they're uh they're genuine critical
scholars they don't force it into a
straitjacket of fundamentalism as their
predecessors did long ago so the people
who are handing these stories down to us
they're not tempting to deceive us they
believe these stories to be true yes oh
yeah it I think there are a few where
there are hints that that they were
written to keep people in line like the
Eden story and the Tower of Babel
stories both say God is threatened by
the potential of the creatures he made
and he doesn't want them to know too
much well that sounds to me like the
priests that want to keep the people
ignorant like Dostoevsky is Grand
Inquisitor there are like in the book of
Acts where Peter kills Ananias and
Sapphira because they welched on their
church pledge that that has to be just a
kind of propaganda scare story
and there's a couple of things the
Gospels like the women at the tomb the
angel says jesus is risen go tell Peter
he'll meet him in Galilee and they leave
and say nothing to anyone how the heck
did mark know about it he said he's
trying to say well oh yeah I know fellow
Christians you never heard about this
empty tomb stuff until now why is that
well it's not as I made it up no no it's
because the women didn't say anything so
there are a handful but on the whole I
don't think you're really dealing with
that it was just imaginative
storytelling and people figured well
this must be it this must be how it
happened
I think this is a good time start
talking about the New Testament then
what is the New Testament where did this
come from well the most folks who study
this think the epistles of Paul were
written in the 50s see II or ad whatever
you prefer and that the Gospels followed
a few decades later but and this is true
of even some myth assists like Richard
carrier and her O'Doherty and so on but
I think they're too conservative believe
it or not I tend to go with the Dutch
radical school of the 19th century Bruno
Bauer WC van Maanen and others said now
it kind of looks like all of these
letters attributed appalled all 13 of
them are suitable graphical that is
written pseudonymous lee that yeah there
was a Paul but he was a famous name and
they just attributed their own stuff to
him critical scholars like Bart Ehrman
today say half of them are not actually
by Paul they can see well yeah this is
an anachronism this is different
literary style and say that half of them
okay he didn't like these 657 he did
will Bauer and van Maanen another said
hold on a second if you apply those
criteria consistently you got to give up
all of them they all appear to be too
Meganium - actually if we know anything
about this all if this stuff couldn't
have been written that early he's
talking of the author's talking about
teeth the traditions that I delivered to
you Paul's teaching you've given a
couple of months before the
Thessalonians is a true teachin and the
various other things and so when were
the Gospels and the epistles written I
tend to lump them all around the very
late first to the mid-second century and
who wrote them we don't know they're
either pseudonymous or anonymous like
the Gospels no names of the texts
they've just been tacked on but Matthew
Mark Luke and John probably in the
second century and of course the Gospels
are narratives of Jesus and as I already
said I think almost all of the narrative
material in them comes from the Old
Testament so they're very very close in
some cases others have big clues the the
book of Acts also is based partly on the
Old Testament hardly on Euripides The
Bacchae that was very influential in the
book of Acts I think and the the
epistles loads of them by different
people and again pseudonymous or
anonymous like the three epistles of
John there's no name on those at all and
so they're in the book of Revelation of
course a big favor I I always enjoy that
one this thing that purports to be a
series of visions of the heavens of the
future that was a common genre we we're
swimming it apocalypses written by Jews
and Christians and they don't really
record anybody's visions that was just a
literary gimmick and again not deceptive
that was just the genre it was a way of
getting your speculations and beliefs
across now many modern Christians see
the Gospels and the gospel stories as
the source of Christianity is that true
though I think the Catholics are right
on this one that it was the church that
produced the
rival not the other way around right and
there were many other books that many
Christians read some of them considered
to be parts of the New Testament even by
church fathers for a while and then they
kind of dropped out of consideration but
they're the earliest Jesus believers
predate the Gospels and this comes up in
in the whole mythos ISM thing the belief
that Jesus didn't a theory Jesus didn't
actually exist as a sorrowful figure
partly because in the Pauline epistles
there's no real discussion of a Jesus
who was a wandering teacher who ever did
any miracles ooh nothing about him
healing and exercising
there's nothing of none of the stuff you
find in the Gospels with one or two
exceptions that kind of look like
they've been added later and why is that
I mean if if Paul for instance if this
is really in writing and in such
material was available I mean teachings
of Jesus surely he come he addresses a
lot of the subjects to come up in the
Gospels why doesn't he quote Jesus and
and so you begin to think well there
were people who believed in some kind of
Jesus before there was any gospel
material wow that's amazing so it seems
to be that the Pauline epistles predate
the Gospels they might but in my view
you can't really tell and it almost
doesn't matter because the the point
would in any case would be that the
group either the person of the group of
people that wrote this knew nothing
about gospel type material sayings
narratives and maybe there they didn't
know about it because the stuff didn't
exist yet we don't know though but if if
the former that just means they seem to
stemmed from a time even if they're
written later they're the epistles seem
to come from a group that maintained an
earlier form of Christianity one without
all this ado about a historical Jesus
now when you look at the four Gospels
do all the Gospels agree on the nature
of Jesus in other words was Jesus born
the Messiah or the son of God or did he
become the Messiah later well it appears
from the earliest of the Gospels mark
that that Jesus becomes the son of God
at his baptism or at his resurrection in
fact it's kind of a compromised document
as William Greider pointed out in the
19th century that he's juggling two
different current Christian views one
that Jesus was the Messiah as of his
resurrection on the other that he had
been made the Son of God his baptism and
he tries to figure out how both to be
true but in either case there's no
pre-existent heavenly jesus and that
view Matthew and Luke seem to believe
Jesus is a kind of a demigod that
there's no Jesus before the the birth in
Bethlehem and he's born the son of God
then and then John's Gospel and knows
nothing of a virgin birth interestingly
and it has people refer to Jesus as the
Son of Joseph with no embarrassment no
correction or anything and it has Jesus
as the earthly incarnation of the Divine
wada-san aspect of God and that existed
with God before the world was created
and so they're they're very different
views it's easy to see how they they
evolve progressively though because if
you say that like in mark at the baptism
it says the vyas the Holy Spirit
descended into him and that's like the
Gnostics and others that said Jesus was
basically the channeler for a heavenly
being an angel etc well then later on
you it's not that much of a step between
saying that and saying that the divine
law boss was in him and maybe event
began earlier nobody ever thought Jesus
lived
for the creation and a human bodies so
it's not that biggest step but in fact
they don't seem to have exactly the same
view of Jesus is there any evidence for
a historical Jesus anything secular know
the the hoopla that never seems to die
about the Josephus the historian who
wrote at the end of the first century
whether he mentions Jesus or not I think
that's been blown out of the water the
the many paragraph in which he discusses
Jesus in our manuscripts which are much
much later than the date of writing it
has been demonstrated to in three
different ways I won't bore you into a
coma with but it couldn't have been
written by the guy that wrote the rest
of this huge book I mean you can tell
what his writing is like etcetera and
that but even if he did write it he's
writing like sixty years after Jesus
would have died and so was he a witness
of Jesus of course not
and nobody denies that that Christians
believed there had been a Jesus by the
end of the first century and so what
would be no but that the same thing with
Tacitus writing about thirty years after
Josie because he knows it's supposedly a
guy named Christus or Crest Asst
manuscripts differ was crucified under
Pontius Pilate but how would he know
this will almost certainly from
Christian preaching so that's that's
evidence for Christianity not for Jesus
and that really is it there really isn't
any now the classic response that Bart
and Herman and others say is that well
you see if you can say that if Jesus was
the miracle-working Superman of the
Gospels they could hardly have avoided
mentioning it in secular sources would
have been big news
but of course critical scholars say no
that stuff is legend we're not
fundamentalist so but but was there a
Jesus around whom
these legends gathered oh yeah there
must have been and that's where I differ
if you if you cut Jesus down to size in
that way you're basically saying oh yeah
there's a hiss there was a historical
Superman all right but he was just Clark
Kent why would anybody have taken notice
of the sky why the Christians have taken
note of them and one more wandering
rabbi I mean there were loads of those
so why and so I don't think there really
is evidence that doesn't mean there
wasn't one but I just think you'd have
to have some better evidence and all
that we wouldn't even take much suppose
we've got old Pyrus letters from this
very period that were preserved in Egypt
and the dry climate nothing big little
notes almost like today's post-it notes
the businessmen would send letters back
to their wives and asking how you do and
here's what I'm up to
suppose we had one of those that where
some merchant said was wife I was in
Jerusalem and chanced to hear the famous
Jesus the Nazarene a teacher of wisdom
suppose that's it like that would be
enough to throw out the whole mythos
hypothesis but there isn't now it maybe
they'll discover one and that'll be it
for emphasis I'm not married to the idea
but failing that we just don't have
anything that would really count as
evidence you know what time it is dr.
price nope
I'll tell you what time it is it's time
for revelation the paperback apocalypse
yes what what is up with that book
that's like an acid trip and as a trip
with dead bodies rising up dragons and
Godzilla's what is the meaning behind
that all the Nifty monsters and boy do I
wish Toho studios would do of
scene-by-scene
because they almost did there's this
really neat movie they did called yamato
takeru base
on Shinto mythology that is a lot like
it I really wish they would anyhow the
monsters come from way back
mythology shared by the Canaanites the
the Babylonians
just about everybody in the ancient
world how did yah they become the king
of gods well there's this great myth
that is same way Marv Duke did the same
way Bale did the same way
Indra did it cetera the gods were
shaking in their boots because of the
threat of the chaos dragons and they
weren't up to the challenge and so one
young virile warrior god of bale Yahweh
center steps forward and said I can take
care of this if you will make me the new
king of the gods because he will have
shown he deserves it as sugar gladly and
so he goes into battle with the dragon
who is described in the Canaanite
sources as a seven headed dragon and
he's called lotin or in hebrew leviathan
because that's the name of a big river
in lebanon the low to the Litani river
it still is in the news a few years ago
of a fight was going on there and they
figure it was a dragon because with us
the twisting serpent like a river and it
had a lot of tributaries hence the the
many heads the Hydra that Hercules
fights hydro means water well that must
have come from the same sort of
personification okay so he does defeat
him though he is eaten and killed in the
process and raised from the dead and
then defeats the dragon becomes king of
the gods and so on very very old myth
him well in the apocalyptic writings
they believe that when this age ended it
would basically repeat the events of the
primordial time the the time of the
creation would be repeated at the end
presaging the creation of a new
and so the the dragon that rises up out
of the sea is Leviathan and when when
Michael the Archangel defeats him he's
taken the place of the young warrior God
Yahweh and so the whole thing and the
fall of the Dragons Satan from heaven
again the same things so a lot of this
comes from that a lot of the rest of
including the horns the trumpets the
Comets the way the locusts from the
bottomless pit are described this is all
ancient astrology that virtually all of
it the 24 elders they're the deckhands
dracco the dragon pursuing the the bird
the woman about to give birth that's
dracco following Virgo and the wheel of
the stars at night virtually everything
is ancient astrology or astronomy
because it's happening in the heavens
yeah it's happening in the heavens so
therefore that that's God's that's
awesome yeah and John says he's taken up
to heaven to see this and was he lying
or did he actually have a hallucinogenic
trip well neither one that was this was
the way the ancient scribes the wise men
wrote down their speculations went
because in other ones like in first
Enoch Enoch goes into the heavens and
they show in the layout of the place
here is where the snowflakes are stored
here's where the raindrops are stored
here's where the lightnings are stored
and they come down out of here I over
here is where the Fallen Angels are
imprisoned and so on and so on how'd
they know that well they just speculated
they figured out that that's the way
it's set up and so how are they going to
publicize it of Enoch the ancient scribe
actually saw this and it was just the
way they publish this stuff and does
that's why all the preoccupation with
the Stars what about the beast and the
Antichrist and all that what are they
talking about
well almost certainly the Beast is
supposed to be the Roman Emperor and
it's a little complicated but we know
the slight
complicated myth it's based on the
Romans thought of Nero as such a great
villain they saw their imagination
couldn't let him go it's just like for
decades
you would hear that you know Hitler
still alive he's down in South America
which wasn't impossible but you know why
did anybody think so it's just you you
don't want to see the last of Darth
Vader I'm looking forward to seeing
rogue one yeah my hero
Darth Vader's yeah same thing and doctor
do Lex Luthor you think they're dead but
no they're going to come back up a
different way about Nero that he had
been killed by the Praetorian Guard and
they said we haven't seen the last of
them I bet he either had a double kill
they used to say that about Saddam
Hussein also and and the real thing
escaped across the Euphrates inter took
refuge in the Parthian Empire or he was
killed but was raised from the dead and
and went to the arthéon's and they were
the the great enemy that Rome feared is
powerful Empire of Persia Afghanistan
etcetera and they they were afraid they
would break through and so they said
well they're going to and Nero
is going to lead the troops and destroy
Rome and revenge and so they this seems
to appear in the book of Revelation
because 666 though it could mean a lot
of things I think almost has to be the
numerical conversion of the the title of
Neron Kaiser Nero Caesar in Greek
because they in Hebrew Greek and Latin
II is the same figures for numbers and
letters you know like Roman numerals
letters same thing in all these
languages and they would add up the
number values and and use that as a kind
of a code for their names and so they
they figured the writer says you know
who I mean because it's all written by
and for scribes who love to like the
parables of Jesus like he who has ears
to hear let him hear it's
get me I'm not going to just throw my
pearls before swine you got to work for
it and so he says his that's the number
of a man his number is 666
so Nero but the book doesn't seem to be
written that early it seems to be
written later and at the end of the
first century and what they probably
mean is that the reigning emperor
Domitian is the resurrected Nero because
there's this weird stuff about how their
seven head and and the Beast is the is
one of the seven and yet a tenth and so
on and so on what is that supposed to
mean and he has a mortal wound that was
healed what sounds like this and that
the latest Emperor really is the return
of one of the previous ones who was dead
and rose and is going to lead the
Parthians across the the afraid he's to
destroy harlot that sits on the Seven
Hills got to be wrong and even the way
the the the scent or the troops of
Parthia are described with hair like the
the hair of women the there that breast
plates of bronze armor and so on there
they're describing the Parthian cavalry
and so it's not that difficult to
penetrate if you know the way these
things were always written and what the
current images were Wow so now whenever
Christians talk about demons it always
seems to be not quite the same thing are
they fallen angels are they the ghosts
of the Evil Dead there seems to be
demonic possession involved sometimes
you know like I said is the Spirit of
God inside Jesus possessing him in a
holy way what are they talking about is
this like some kind of a demon
possession cult Christianity well yeah
they didn't cultivate it like in the
Voodoo religion words the the spirits of
gods that they're summoning and they
have like divine ecstasy though you
could say Pentecost
kind of arrived but demon-possession
was usually a an explanation for illness
that was intractable in medicine didn't
help and and so they figure out what the
heck is going on it's it must be you the
devil is victimizing him with his
flunkies that the demons holding people
hostage basically and so if we can gain
power over the the prince of demons we
can twist his arm and force him to let
him go which is where the stuff comes
about ISA comes from with he's casting
out demons by Beelzebub a friends of the
demons old Exorcist did that well what
were these things in the life of
Apollonius of Tyana contemporary miracle
worker Annie Oakley Gurian preacher
there it's pretty clear that when he
casts out demons it is the ghosts of the
wicked dead okay and then they tend to
be vampires also vampires were type of
ghosts in the ancient world but in a
Jewish literature the New Testament
period we're told that um the demons
were fallen angels or the ghosts of the
Nephilim once they died uncle's versions
and they're very similar stories and the
in the book of Jubilees the fallen angel
masty mouths I suppose the same as Satan
he he is stationed as the tempter
because in the Old Testament he actually
wasn't a bad guy most of the time he put
people on trial except sting operations
see if they were really loyal to God or
not like job for instance well so he's
got his job to do there but God is going
to sentence all of his cohorts who
joined him in rebellion to the
netherworld to be chained in the
darkness an idea just comes right out
Greek mythology the Titans of the Giants
were chained up down there and mastema
says well if I'm to do my job I'm going
to need some staff and he says give me a
tenth of the of the Fallen Angels to do
my work is okay so you've got that most
of them in prison underground but you've
got a lot of them inhabiting the lower
heavens right at different concentric
domed heavens and they're around causing
mischief well the so they're causing
illness especially epilepsy in fact the
word epilepsy means literally being
seized upon epi and Lex's you're being
soon seized upon by some alien agent and
this was a diagnostic category because
they didn't know I mean how could they
know what was actually happening and so
he said it must be an invasive
possession and so it was it's like again
imaginative pre scientific reasoning and
now the more interesting part of it was
the doctrine of the principalities and
powers which took the sons of God thing
in a different direction and retained
the notion that they ruled the the
nations that the idea of demon
possession is different but it's just
branching off the same myth
so that yahwehís or El Elyon assigned a
rim on Syria okay you rule Syria and
this one to that and bail rules this and
Thoth rules that when they kept that
even though they vilified the sons of
God oh they shouldn't matter with those
mortal women they went wrong they fell
and so forth but this came in handy as
an explanation too because they said why
is government so irredeemably corrupt I
mean it's terrible today but it was
the rule in the ancient world naturally
you paid off people or nothing got done
and there was no control over people and
yet it was better than chaos Hobbes's
war of all against all we don't want
that it's like if the mob rules Chicago
that's bad but it would be worse if not
even they were there and so they had
this actually sophisticated view of the
principalities and powers in heavenly
places and it's a perfect way of
describing of what actually happens in
the world people start multinational
corporations or whatever they grow
beyond human control they're their own
entities in a strange way and so it's a
perfect myth for that and in fact I
don't think you can really understand
what's going on in cases like that
without this myth not believing it but
it articulates so well and so that that
kept the idea that they were the rulers
of the earth and this ties in to the
book of Revelation and all of that
apocalyptic stuff because they said look
we don't know why God allowed them to
take over but it's going to be moot soon
because he's going to take over like in
the book of Revelation the kingdoms of
this world have become the kingdoms of
our Lord and of his Christ and he shall
reign forever and ever yeah that's how
its Trump voters feel after Obama and
Clinton were cast down from it and it's
just as an analogy editorializing but
it's the idea thank god that's over or
it soon will be and maybe God will tell
us how he allowed things to go that way
when we get to heaven but I don't really
care as long as it's over and so that
was the great hope of apocalyptic
awesome what are you working on now you
working on a book yeah a book called
Bart Ehrman interpreted a little play on
one of his titles Jesus interrupted and
he's a friend of mine and I enjoy his
books but I find a lot of people like
both his stuff and my
and wonder why I don't agree more with
him or he with me and so this the idea
of this book is to take what I think are
his major views and show why I differ so
it's not really polemical but it's
saying here's what I think he's saying
here's why I don't buy that but do buy
this and so it's like an ironic sketch
of the differences between us and I'm
having a lot of fun reading for it and
writing it I've got great titles like
that the title on his book Jesus before
the Gospels I think it is about oral
tradition my chapter on that is called
blessed or the cheesemakers his chapter
on textual criticism like what the Bible
actually originally say can we weed out
the copyist errors my chapter on that is
called when I get that feeling I want
textual healing I'm encouraging all our
viewers to go to the Bible geek look up
dr. Robert M price Bible geek on YouTube
and subscribe to him there's a lot of
really good stuff there on his on his uh
on his channel interviews he answers
questions and anything you'd like to
plug Gawker so uh before to awfully long
I have a massive two volumes set of
books coming out called holy fable the
Old Testament undistorted by faith and
then the New Testament undistorted by
faith and it's it deals with almost
every book of the Bible giving a kind of
an introduction introduction to each one
and a kind of flying commentary on major
stuff and I'm pretty pleased with it
that that's the first one should be out
a few months I guess that's great
awesome okay dr. price it was an honor
to have you on and and I you know I ask
your forgiveness sometimes they get a
little tongue-tied around you I get
starstruck when I'm talking to you I've
been listening to you for years but it's
really weird to actually you know see
you face to face so even though it's
just the videos
but thanks for coming off thanks for
having thank you very much for being on
the show
fantastic show okay hopefully you guys
enjoyed that interview like I said as
much as we enjoyed doing it yeah we're
gonna have him back and we will
definitely have him back I'm talking
about Lovecraft or maybe you know
expanding on this topic to maybe in the
future um you know like he was saying
please check out his YouTube channel the
Bible geek you can just google the Bible
geek and find all the stuff he's written
like a million books you know some
Lovecraft some biblical stuff some Jesus
mythos is stuff and it's all really
great so be sure to check that out and
if you like our show then you know
please download audio from Project
Entertainment Network watch the YouTube
show a Twitter page Facebook page for 13
o'clock podcasts you guys know and also
just a reminder we still have five
different designs of t-shirts at
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock so if you
want to go check those out we'll be
putting up some more designs probably
eventually and actually if you have any
suggestions for any designs you'd like
these based on any of our other topics
then let me know and I will yeah just
drop us a comment box yeah just drop in
the comment box for or you know wherever
you're listening to it and I will try
and accommodate you eventually still
like to have real shirt I know I'm gonna
I'll get you one we don't even have any
yet know anybody why don't we we need to
get some of our okay so hope you guys
enjoy the show and remember to tune in
next Tuesday
you